democrats want to pack the supreme court
packing the court is when you increase
the number of judges
on the court and to justify their calls
to pack the supreme court
often explicit calls to pack the supreme
court they accused republicans
of packing the supreme court and they
did this by redefining the term
packing the court to mean just replacing
the judges when vacancies
come up on the court instead of adding
to the number of judges on the court so
that was the old strategy
now though they've gone even further
while they're trying to pack the court
they are now saying that they are not
only not packing the court but they are
in fact
unpacking the court some people will say
we're packing the court we're not
packing it we're unpacking it
we're unpacking it says jerry nadler
yeah come on up is down come on truce
falls
left is right east is west come on
democrats yet again
attempting to redefine reality by
redefining all the words i'm michael
moses the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from hefty jongle
something tells me that's not his
christian name who says the new most
dangerous game
is taking a shot every time knowles
plugs his book
at least my friday nights would become
extra entertaining that is a very
very scary game because one imagines
that
not too long into my show you would have
taken so many shots that that would have
rendered you
speechless which by the way is the name
of my new of course
i can't even get through it available
now for pre-order do you know
if you do play the knowles book
drinking game the pre-order drinking
game and you are absolutely
wrecked because of how many times i've
plugged my upcoming book
you know what's going to make you feel
better the next day liquid iv when you
push your body hard or you just feel run
down it's very important to stay
hydrated
with one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces
of water
you will get two to three times the
amount of hydration as plain water
contains five essential vitamins
more vitamin c than an orange and as
much potassium as a banana
healthier than sugary sports drinks no
artificial flavors or preservatives and
less sugar than an apple this is really
helpful i never prioritized getting
enough water getting
getting enough hydration which is how i
got my under eye bags now i know that
some people
some good people who exercise and work
out and stuff like that they
love liquid iv because it helps hydrate
them after a workout if you're like me
maybe you have a couple adult beverages
with the boys
and the next morning feels a little
better thanks to liquid iv which you can
grab in bulk nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
and use code michael at checkout that is
25 off anything you order
when you get better hydration today
using promo code michael mich ael
liquid iv.com the left always does this
sort of thing
this is probably their most consistent
strategy
which is to redefine reality or attempt
to redefine reality
by redefining all the words that's
basically the definition of political
correctness
and they're doing that here with court
packing however there is a little
glimmer of hope
for those of us who want to keep some
semblance of our constitutional republic
namely nancy pelosi is not
gung-ho about bringing this court
packing bill to the floor
i support the president's commission to
study
such a proposal but
frankly i'm not right now
our we're back our members our
committees are working we're building
the empress putting together the
infrastructure bill and the rest
i don't know that that's a good idea or
a bad idea i think it's an idea that
should be considered
and i think the president's taking the
right approach to
to have a commission to study such a
thing it's a big step
it's not out of the question it has been
done before
in the history of our country a long
time ago and the growth of our country
the size of our country the growth of
our challenges in terms of
the economy etc might necessitate such a
thing
but it answers your question i have no
plans to bring it to the floor
no plans to bring it to the floor this
is a little bit of a side note i don't
like watching people talk when they've
got a mask on it makes them look like
cartoon villains it makes them look like
banditos it's it's weird it's creepy i
don't like it
and she shouldn't be doing that all of
that said i am pleased to see that nancy
pelosi is now really only trying to use
court packing
as a bargaining chip but she is
suggesting she is implying here that she
does not
actually want to pack the supreme court
the fact that this is so popular on the
left though and among democrats is just
exhibit z i don't know exhibit
z times 50 of the
disingenuousness that you hear from
democrats when they accuse trump of
upending constitutional norms and
threatening our democracy because he
sent a tweet or something or whatever
said something that he didn't even say
that the democrats pretended he said
the democratic party is trying to force
in
new states to give them a permanent
majority the the democrats are trying to
turn the district of columbia the
federal district that is never supposed
to be
a state by definition it is not supposed
to be a state trying to turn it into a
state and they're trying to pack the
supreme court so i just don't want to
hear it i never want to hear another
word
about donald trump and the
constitutional norms the left
doesn't actually care about
constitutional norms because the left
hates the constitution
and so they're trying to upend all of
society and not just
our foundational legal document the
constitution
but all of it all the institutions all
the traditions that is the plan of the
cultural radicals
and conservatives are playing a fool's
game
when they try to win the debate by
showing
the illogic of the left's plans there is
no logic here if jerry nadler can walk
on tv and say we're not going to pack
the court we're going to unpack the
court
anyway yeah we're going to do what we
want we're going to grab power and we're
going to grab money and that's just the
way it is
this is not just happening at the level
of elected office
is happening throughout the culture the
associated press
which has long not only given in to
political correctness and woke language
but has
in some ways led the charge in the past
they
are now banning the people who follow
the ap guidelines from using the term
mistress
what's a mistress a mistress is a lady
who's sleeping with a married man right
no no longer the ap style book says
quote
don't use the term mistress for a woman
who's in a long-term sexual relationship
with
and is financially supported by a man
who is married to someone else
instead use an alternative like
companion
friend or lover on first reference
and provide additional details later now
you see the problem with uh
friend say i i am friends with andrew
clavin
and andrew clavin is a married man i do
not want there to be any confusion
about the nature of our relationship so
you've got these very vague words
friend companion they're really they
don't tell you anything
then you've got a more specific word
lover but they're all sorts of lovers
people can have lovers in a perfectly
above-board way or at least relatively
above-board way
but when you're sleeping with a married
man that's not above board that's wrong
that's sinful you shouldn't be doing
that sort of thing
but we're not allowed to use the term
mistress whatever term you end up using
is going to acquire
negative connotations this is called the
euphemism treadmill stephen pinker who
is no conservative but he's a harvard
professor
he pointed this out a number of years
ago now
the idea of the euphemism treadmill is
that
radicals want to deny harsh realities so
they sugarcoat them
with euphemisms however
over time the realities remain and so
the reality is because they continue to
assert themselves
will recolor the euphemism that people
add to it so whatever words you're going
to make up for mistress it's going to
take on
a negative connotation this is true for
people who
have mental deficiencies in
initially terms like simpleton or idiot
or [ __ ]
were or [ __ ] for that matter were
you might say euphemistic they were
terms that were trying to describe
in a way that was relatively polite and
inoffensive
this deficiency but because the
deficiency is not
particularly desirable you know it's a
it's
a by definition it's a deficiency over
time
it takes on a negative connotation and
so rather than just trying to
be compassionate to people who have not
just mental deficiencies but all sorts
of divisions and we've all got something
instead what these linguistic
verbal hygienists want to do these
cultural radicals want to do
is just come up with a new term and they
think that's going to change the
underlying reality it doesn't really
happen
and i don't want to just strawman the
ap's argument here
the ap goes a little bit further they
say quote
we added this guidance last year it's
not new we understand it's problematic
that the alternative terms fall short
like suggesting that
if i am friends with andrew clavin that
implies something that nobody wants to
think about
but they write we felt that was better
than having one word for a woman
and none for the man and implying that
the woman was solely responsible for the
affair
well it doesn't imply that the woman is
solely responsible for the affair there
are all sorts of terms for a man
who cheats on his wife with some woman
you call him a cat you can call him an
adulterer you can call him a womanizer i
said oh
plenty of terms for that but you're
right it's not the same term
it's different you wouldn't call a man
who's in a similar kind of relationship
a mistress but the words are different
not because of the unfairness of our
language and the patriarchy
the words are different because the
sexes are different
and the sexes are very different in this
regard
very rarely are you going to find a
young man
who is in a who's who is a kept man from
an
older woman you know he's pursuing this
older woman who's got a family but she's
cheating on her husband
with this younger man and it's an
illicit relationship but you know she
keeps them up in
a nice apartment or something like that
that's just not how it works
men and women have different
relationships to
sex their sexual desires are of a
different character
the the significance of sex to them is
of a different nature
the the things that men would do
if they were not hemmed in by the moral
order and our marital vows
sexually are different than the
behaviors that women would engage in
feminism seeks to deny this leftism
broadly
seeks to deny this because they cannot
stand the difference between men and
women it's why they're so obsessed now
with
redefining men to become women and women
to become men and
and defining sex as a social construct
but there actually is a difference and
that's why there are different words
and you can try to change the words but
it's just not going to change
that reality i'll give you an example of
trying to sugarcoat evil
with sweet and soft words npr is just
reporting this right now
for the first time us and chinese
scientists have created embryos that are
part human
part monkey in an effort to find new
ways to produce organs for transplants
but some ethicists worry about how such
research could go wrong
gee you don't say some some ethicists
are worried
even here what is this scientists have
created so it's the scientists have
graded it right even though it's
one imagines these scientists are backed
by not just national
political cooperation but international
political cooperation they've created
embryos what's an embryo an embryo is a
human it's a person
they're part human but part monkey and
they're just doing it to try to find new
ways to produce
organs for transplants
in plain english what that says is that
these chinese and u.s
scientists obviously with political
support are creating
human hybrids breeding them so that they
can kill them and harvest them for
organs
so that those of us who are currently
older
who have survived birth
can live maybe a little bit longer
scientists are now trying to create a
human hybrid
specifically for the purpose of
sacrificing that creature
so that we can eke out a little bit
longer in this life so we can steal
their organs
and put them in our own bodies and live
a little bit longer
the ethical concerns i don't think are
that the research will go wrong
i think it's gone pretty wrong already
people are just not aware they don't
have perspective if you want perspective
on the outside of your home though
you've got to check out
ring so much is going on at our front
doors these days that is one thing that
has not changed for me it's gotten
even crazier you know my cute little
bundle of joy
a lot a lot more people coming in the
door you got the people dropping off the
food you got the people dropping off the
toys and
and the clothing and you got the in-laws
too
so sometimes you're going to open that
door sometimes you're going to close it
really helps to know who's
out there which you can do with ring
ring will allow you to see and speak
to whoever is outside your door whether
you are in the living room
or maybe you're in your bedroom or maybe
you're at the office or maybe you're
on a beach in tahiti it doesn't matter
where you are
by the way even if the person doesn't
ring the bell motion detection means you
will be notified
you can see what's going on wherever you
are really makes me feel safe when i'm
on the road
you know knowing that sweet little elise
and cute little june will be able to
know who is outside that door before
they open that door makes a great
housewarming gift too especially because
it's not that expensive so great gift
don't have to spend a lot of money
right now get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit at ring.com
knowles comes with rings video doorbell
3 and chime pro the perfect way
to upgrade your front door and start
your ring experience go to ring dot com
slash knowles kw las
ring.com knowles these scientists
in the us and china this is being
reported by npr it's not
like it's some fringe website that
pushes conspiracy theories on the
internet actually i guess it's npr so it
is a sort of fringe website that pushes
conspiracy theories but
they consider themselves mainstream
they're backed up by taxpayer dollars
and the liberal establishment
and they're trying to present this idea
that we're going to breed
sort of semi-humans and harvest their
organs
for ourselves they're trying to say this
is a good thing that's a good it's a
wonderful thing you know a bioethicist
at case western reserve university in
harvard
in su hyun says quote i don't see this
type of research
being ethically problematic it's aimed
at
lofty humanitarian goals
well there it is breeding a a race of
semi people to kill them and take their
organs that's
but it's it's for the purpose of helping
old rich people today live a little
longer
isn't that come on that's great it's a
that's a lofty humanitarian goal
reminds us that the religion of
humanitarianism
is a very wicked religion indeed because
what it tries to do
is divorce it tries to keep some of
christianity but without christianity
and it ultimately turns our attention
away from god toward just ourselves and
it leads to a radical sort of
selfishness
in in the guise of this really moral
compassionate language like you see here
there is nothing
i cannot imagine a single more selfish
thing
than breeding people to steal their
organs
or breeding half people or
creating a new race that is somewhat
human
just for yourself we used to
recognize in this culture that death
comes for us all
and that there are some things that are
worse than death
i've talked now for over a year about
the neurotic hysteria
that people have descended into during
covid
because it seems they're just waking up
to the fact that they could die and by
the way the covid
death rate is pretty low but even that
is freaking people out and causing us to
upend our society
because people don't want to confront
the fact of death they want to push it
to the side
they want to deny it they want to avert
it all together if they can which is a
fool's errand
they don't believe in eternal things
they don't believe that there can be a
life after death they think
gosh you know all those stories about
christianity those are fairy tales
that's really
how could anyone with two brain cells to
rub together believe in that
god you know all those idiots like um i
don't know thomas aquinas
or uh and all those really dum-dums like
uh pope benedict xvi or uh you know
isaac newton or i don't know all the
smartest people ever who have ever lived
you know those guys they believe in
crazy ridiculous stuff
and so we because we're rational because
we're scientific because we
understand what's right we are going to
create monkey human hybrids to
to steal all their organs and put them
in our own bodies
to live a little bit longer uh something
went wrong there
we need to turn not to these experts who
are obviously ethically idiotic
is that is that the politically correct
term what term am i supposed they're
simpletons they're morons i don't know
what term i'm supposed to use
we should turn to people in the culture
like this ufc fighter who
i had never heard of before because i
don't really follow the sport but she is
great and she's much smarter than
any of these of these experts around us
rose namahunas is that uh namajunas
nahonas i don't know
she made this point in an interview that
for her she would rather be dead than
red i
have i have a lot to fight for in this
fight and
what she represents and um you know
uh i was just i was just kind of
reminding myself of you know
all the my background and everywhere
that i come from and my family and
everything like that and
we watched um and i kind of wanted to
educate my
training partner of chico camus on uh
the lithuanian struggle and like just
the history of it all and um so we watch
the other dream team just to kind of get
like a
overall sentiment of what we fight for
and um so just the
after watching that it was just a huge
reminder of like yeah it's better
better dead than red you know and i
think um
i don't think it's any coincidence that
whaley is red
you know she's uh that's what she
represents it's nothing personal against
her
but um that's a huge motivating factor
of why i fight and i fight for freedom
so this fighter she goes on it's very
eloquent she i guess this other fighter
that she's referring to is some sort of
pinko
and she says look we have we actually
have different values here
i would rather be dead than red yes
that's not just jingoist slogans that
americans used to
recite during the cold war that is a
moral truth
i would rather be dead than red
this goes right back to the bible when
christ says do not fear those
who can destroy your body but destroy
but but fear him
who can destroy your body and your soul
in hell
you should you should not only be
worried about your physical safety all
the time that will
that will deprive you of your dignity
and you're going to end up
well i guess we're we're living in a
moment when people are denying human
dignity more broadly
by creating little hybrids in in
laboratories and by trying to compost
humans as we
were discussing yesterday on the show
but i still believe that humans have
dignity i still think we have a rational
soul we have an intellect and a will and
that we should we're made in the image
of god i believe all of that and so if i
were forced into a
political system that demanded they told
me
you need to embrace our radical
atheist materialist system
called communism or we're going to kill
you it wouldn't take me two seconds
say oh kill me i'm not afraid i'm not
afraid of death i don't want to suffer
i'm not exactly happy about pain
i don't want to endure that but death
itself
no i'd like to extend my life reasonably
but
you know i'd like to like to live a good
life in accordance with providence
but i know ultimately i'm going to die
and so i don't fear that i want to just
make sure that i'm in a
i'm in a good position when i die i
don't i don't think it's necessarily
wrong for researchers to be trying to
figure out ways to improve human health
but there's a big difference between
researching ways to improve human health
and creating and destroying
human-like creatures you know semi-human
creatures
for the purpose of living
by their death that is an inversion
of well it's an inversion of
christianity it's an inversion of the
religion that has traditionally built
our civilization
and it's an inversion of all the lines
that we talk about about how we need to
be progressive and selfless and open and
yeah it's all
bunk it's all total bunk speaking of
reds by the way
cnn this poor schlub this this technical
director from cnn who got caught on
james o'keefe's
sting operation o'keefe has released a
new video
in which this cnn technical director
explains that cnn wants to help
blm i was trying to do some research
like the asian
heat like that you know people are
getting attacked
apache
you know um
that's not good at the optics without
enough kid these
little things like that are enough to
set back movements you know
because the the far left will start to
latch on and create a story
of like um criminalizing
an entire people you know just easy
easier headlines that way i guess it's
easier it's easier headline they just
want to help
blm that's all they're trying to do but
sometimes the reality
is contradicting the blm narrative and
it's just really frustrating if you're a
reporter at cnn
because then you know there is a lot of
pressure for you to report the news but
you're not there to report the news
you're there to push a narrative
that is not in accordance with reality
and gosh that's really frustrating i
kind of feel bad for this guy
because i think he thought he was just
impressing some chick on a date and
instead he's just
spilling secrets that are now
well they are they are depicting i think
the reality speaking of blm too
i have to get back to this story that
we've talked about the last couple days
there's there's more development on it
you know that the blm founder patrice
cullers
has been buying up lots of super fancy
houses they've renamed blm
by large mansions so she came out she
denied it she said i'm not taking money
unfairly out of blm
and then the new york city blm chapter
said wait hold on what are you guys
doing
at least give us a cut as i think the
implication but hey i this seems
like it's not totally above board well
now we figured out how she got her money
according to the daily caller uh a los
angeles jail reform organization paid
jania and patrice consulting i guess
this is a firm that patrice callers owns
paid her 20 000 a month while she served
as the chairwoman
of the it's a ridiculous term in itself
well she served as the chairman of the
jail reform group
this consulting firm received a total of
191 000
over the course of 2019 via payments
from reform la jails
that's just one organization paying them
huge amounts of money how many other
organizations was patrice cullers on the
take from
in extortion efforts so she can't say no
i wasn't taking the money from the blm
organization i don't take a penny from
them
i just shake down all the companies on
my own through my consulting firm so i
don't even need to go through
blm man oh man is that woman
crafty i i need to plan
a similar kind of strategy and
if i'm really going to sit there and try
to strategize and work this out
i know i'm going to want to be an
ex-chair ex-chair has you covered for
your office chair
needs the secret is not only their
patented dynamic
variable lumbar support which offers
incredible lumbar support i really like
that for the lower back
but now thanks to their new xhmt
technology you can also get
heat and massage therapy while you were
sitting at your desk
you know that sort of thing if you were
getting massages and stuff like that at
your desk and that would that could get
you in trouble
but now with the x chair it's totally
cool it's totally above board i did not
know
that chairs could be this sophisticated
this fancy
really amazing stuff the x chair is on
sale right now for 100
off go to xshareknowles.com right now
that is letter x
chair canon wlas.com or call 1-844
x chair has a 30 day guarantee of
complete comfort you can finance your
purchase
for as little as 30 bucks a month go to
externals.com right now use
code x wheels for free x-wheel blade
casters
externals.com so
blm is not we're now beginning to find
out how these radicals are making their
money
the the way they're doing is they
fundraise for the organization which is
just
the militant wing of the democrat party
but then these founders of blm like
patrice colors are buying up all these
zillion dollar homes it seems
because they're shaking down all the
other shell organizations
on their own through their own political
consulting firm what consulting is this
woman giving
it's just an extortion front which a lot
of race hustlers have done over the
years this is nothing new al sharpton
used to do the same thing
this woman just seems to have gotten
more efficient about it
and i i can't blame her i blame her
because her goals are evil and bad
and because she's contributing to the
destruction of the country that i love
so
i blame her for that but just from a
pure
political operations standpoint
i give her a lot of credit i wish
conservatives knew how to do this sort
of thing i wish republicans knew how to
behave in this sort of way
what she is doing what she has
recognized first of all is that
big politics attracts big money and both
of those
sorts of things will give you a lot of
influence
and she's just practicing that and she's
amassing for herself
a lot of money and a lot of political
influence and then she is exercising
that influence not just to buy herself
nice swimming pools or whatever
because she's doing that too but to
advance her political agenda if only
conservatives could do that
you know i'm not saying conservatives
should be immoral in any way or that we
should
should violate any any of the moral
order
but i wish that we understood what
political
power is and how to exercise it because
the left is much much better at it
they're very very effective
speaking of political campaigns hitting
a little bit of a snafu
the confidence in the coronavirus
vaccine is plummeting right now this
according to an economist yougov poll
so you know that the johnson johnson
vaccine went on pause because there was
apparently a blood clotting issue in
certain rare cases
it was killing people so
among those surveyed before the
announcement of the johnson and johnson
pause
52 of respondents said that the vaccine
was very safe or somewhat safe
twice the number of people who believed
it was very unsafe or somewhat unsafe
after the announcement about johnson and
johnson came out those figures seemed to
change quite a bit only 37 of the
respondents felt the vaccine was safe
and 39
felt that the vaccine was unsafe and
it's not just the johnson johnson
vaccine
blood clot deaths related to the vaccine
have apparently been reported in italy
and denmark from astrazeneca denmark has
now removed the astrazeneca vaccine
i mentioned this a little bit on the
show yesterday i think it bears
reiterating
i'm not saying that the vaccine is
totally unsafe
i'm not saying that you are likely to
get a blood clot if you take the vaccine
i'm not saying that under no
circumstance would i take the vaccine
what i am saying is there is a
prudential risk
calculation whenever you're getting any
sort of medical procedure
and the public health eggheads the liars
in lab coats such as dr fauci
but all the other people that dr fauci
represents he's just the high pontiff in
the
in the church of secular progressivism
when they told us
no risk whatsoever everyone's got to get
the vaccine don't
don't calculate your actual risk from
the virus just go get it get it get it
you have to get it you have to get it
there's no risk whatsoever
they were obviously lying to you because
there is always a risk
might be a small risk but there are
risks and by the way i think the
reaction to it the pause on the vaccines
i think we can blame the same public
health eggheads
who have been misleading us and in some
cases lying to us
over the past year because their
credibility is completely
shot so when people when whatever it is
39 of people say they think the vaccines
are unsafe
i can't blame them but michael only
seven people got the blood clot issue
out of
seven million vaccinated okay fine i
just wish
that the public health experts had been
more forthright from the beginning
because then we wouldn't have this
problem of credibility would we then
people could exercise prudence which is
a virtue you're not allowed to talk
about anymore
but it is a core conservative virtue
the radicals seem to be running the show
it's not just these radicals running
through the streets burning down the
cities them too
but they seem to be in positions of
serious power in the biden
administration
kristen clarke who we sounded the alarm
on months ago when her name was floated
for the biden administration
she is up for the u.s department of
justice civil rights division she's
supposed to lead that division it's a
very powerful division
i talk about her actually at great
length in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling mine's
available now for pre-order by the way
this woman is a radicals radical she
published an article at harvard in the
harvard crimson
about how black people are superior to
white people because of the melanin in
their skin
the same kooky theories that nick cannon
the actor was spouting off on
some months ago the same kooky theories
that professor jeffries famously this
crazy professor in new york was spatting
off on
years and years ago this woman was
pushing the same stuff and she's up for
a leadership role in the
doj civil rights division senator cruz
absolutely wrecking this woman during
her
testimony your advocacy and
frank frankly extreme position on
defunding the police
is paired with a history of not only
excusing
but celebrating murderers who have
murdered police officers
it's been reported that during law
school you helped organize a conference
with speakers
who referred to convicted cop killers as
political prisoners
did you organize the conference and do
you support
celebrating those who murder police
officers
as heroes and and political prisoners
i was a student providing logistical
support to a
notable historian who was the one who
organized that conference so if there's
a police officer in philadelphia or new
jersey today watching this hearing
how are they supposed to react to your
nomination to one of the senior
positions of the department of justice
knowing that as a student you
participated in a conference
celebrating and lionizing cop killers
no well it goes on you should you should
take a listen to the whole exchange
this woman basically denying that she
said what she said
this woman said no no they have forget
the headlines that that have been
written on my articles forget what i've
written in articles no no i don't
believe that
no no like jerry nadler says we're not
trying to pack the court we're going to
unpack the court what
what are you talking you can't just you
can't
just use your words to contradict
reality perfectly contradict reality
and then hope that on the strength of
your redefinition and your euphemisms
you will actually create the word anew i
don't care how narcissistic how prideful
you are you ain't going to succeed at
that
the left keeps doing it chunk uger big
left winger
he tweeted out the other day now people
are saying they won't travel to red
states because it's a danger
to be around conservatives nearly half
of republicans say they won't take the
vaccine
it's literally hazardous to your health
to be around this death cult
their ignorance has reached a clinical
level i think he's suggesting here that
because
conservatives just by being who they are
are
are a health threat that would justify a
public health response what does that
mean
can get pretty dark there i i love too
that people who have been living in the
neurotic fear of death
like inside their own homes afraid of
the the woofloo for a year
call the rest of us a death cult but
he's he's also just wrong on the numbers
by raw count six out of the top ten
states right now for covid cases
are democrat-run states they're not
republican-run states 60
and then if you look at the seven-day
case rate per 100 000 people in the
population
the top 10 states are all run by
democrats every single one
so even just on the pure facts the data
the science what's going on in reality
democrats case does not it completely
falls apart
but the the left like chang like this
woman kristen clarke like
jerry nadler they believe that they can
change the reality with their very words
don't let them do that
you got to listen to the best words
folks if you want some great words check
out
candace's show tonight streams 9 pm
eastern 8 pm central
at dailywire.com but you can get the
audio podcast canvas
at applespotify or wherever you listen
to your podcasts
obviously candace owens great friend of
mine a really terrific voice in the
conservative movement
we really need you to go over there
subscribe leave a five star review
for candace the podcast not because she
needs the listens or anything like that
obviously the show's doing great
but mostly because if if it does really
well in the ratings and everything
then i think we get to all rename our
show so i can just be michael i've
always i've always
more or less wanted to be share so you
know if i just get that one name that
would really be great go check it out
we'll be right back
with the mailbag
welcome back to the mailbag first
question from william who writes
hey michael you denounced the idea of
composting your remains as
debasing or savaging the decorum of the
station we as god's chosen creation
hold i understand the point you were
making but i disagree
when i saw the possibility of being
composted in the future
i immediately told my wife that is what
i wanted if it was available
those close enough to me to be concerned
with my physical remains have a saving
relationship with their creator and i
can think of no greater use or service
for my physical remains than to feed my
children's tomato plants
and my creator's world did you have a
deeper theological objection to this
practice or was it simply
that you personally think it debases
god's creation well my personal opinion
is based on my theological views
but there's a more practical
consideration namely your kids don't
want to eat you in a tomato
my friend i see the impulse of what
you're saying well we'll all be part of
creation
but i fear that that has more to do with
the
modernist pseudo-religion of
environmentalism or gaia the
idea that we're all just going to be
part of the world man you are more than
worm food my friend you are more than a
tomato
you have a special place in creation you
are made in the image of god
you have base appetites you have aspects
of you that are kind of
animalistic that make you in some ways
like the
human monkey hybrid that the the
psychopaths in
lab coats are currently creating but you
also have a higher
rational will and intellect which
mediates between your base animal nature
and the divine will and hopefully as you
practice the virtues and grow in
sanctity and holiness you can
you can focus more on that one and less
on the bottom one but you
you are not uh a tomato and you
you should not be a tomato and we all
have a natural repugnance i think at
this when you think about the reality of
it
you might have a sort of rationalist
ethereal out in the pie in the sky idea
of what that would be like and why it's
so nice
but if someone served you your daddy in
a tomato
something tells me you would not want to
eat it and there is a great wisdom
in that repugnance not the least of
which because if
if you're a christian the traditional
christian expectation
is that we look forward to the
resurrection of the body in the life of
the world to come
does this mean that your body needs to
remain perfectly incorrupt
for all of history and if it starts to
decay in any way that you're you're
totally
uh up the river no i don't think that's
that's what we're saying here but
what it's saying is that the body has
some significance to you
you are not truly a soul that happens to
be kind of briefly attached to the body
but the body doesn't really matter
that's that is the argument of the
transgenderists that's the argument of
the gnostics
or the albigensians or all sorts of
other kooky sex that have cropped up in
history but the body actually has
something to do with who you are
and in the resurrection in the in that
after christ comes again and the
resurrection of the body the body will
have something to do with you
then too and i think that is why we need
to treat the body
with some respect both now and after we
turn to what many people would consider
to be
worm food from sophia hey michael i live
in israel where our government has
instituted the green passport for people
who have been vaccinated against kovan
19
those who choose not to be vaccinated
like me are treated as second-class
citizens and are barred from certain
events hotels etc
the israeli version of the green
passport has become the model for the uk
and other countries in europe this is a
massive infringement of our human rights
privacy assembly etc
and has made our lives increasingly more
difficult my question is
if america does not go along with the
green passport do you think this global
initiative is dead in the water
as a global initiative i think it is
because the united states whether we
want to admit it or not is the global
hegemon
the china now is an emerging superpower
but the u.s still dominates and we like
to pretend that we're just our own
country and you know other countries or
other countries but we
we run the world that's just the way it
goes and
so if we
disallowed these sorts of things if we
prohibited green passports in the united
states like ron desantis is doing
like tate reeves is doing in mississippi
like other governors are taking the lead
on here
then i think it would it would have a
lot a lot greater trouble being
instituted around the world
especially for tourism you know when
people rely on american tourist dollars
so this this is a fight i think we
absolutely should fight
not even because i'm totally against
vaccines or something like that but
something really seems to have cracked
here in the country we are
we are freaking out over this virus
in a way that we haven't freaked out
over other deadlier viruses and it's not
because the science has changed it's
because the philosophy and the religion
have changed and that's really bad for
the culture that's much more dangerous
to the body politic than the virus is to
the body
from cameron dear michael i'm a 20 year
old female conservative
at a very liberal university because of
this it's challenging to get career
slash future advice from someone who
shares my values i plan to attend law
school and become a lawyer because i'm
passionate about fighting injustices
like human trafficking
however i also hold deep family values
and am worried
a career will get in the way of my being
a mother everyone i talk to thinks my
career is
much more valuable because of the whole
women empowerment thing i agree
but raising a family is much more
empowering to me
how do i know i'm making the right
decisions amidst all the liberal
nonsense thank you for all you do
raise a family get married and raise a
family
that is what you should do that is much
more important than you going to law
school
and doing whatever else you want to do
you can be involved in the causes you
want to be involved in
you should ignore all of the lib
dummies who are telling you to ruin your
life and you should instead get married
and raise a family
would i give this advice to every single
woman no i was actually talking to a
friend of mine
last night who is having a little bit of
a crisis in this uh in this regard as
well
or at least having questions about it i
do not deny
that there is some very small number of
women
who truly have a total aversion to
raising a family and who really just
need to be
working in some career and they're
really really drawn to that i'm not
denying that that is true
but the fact that in your question you
are questioning that
right the entire culture is telling you
you've got to put off having kids put
off getting married
work at the widget shop become a middle
manager work on spreadsheets
that's the most important thing in life
is spreadsheets and making widgets and
stuff
the fact that even amid all that
ridiculous noise you still think god
you kind of i kind of want to raise a
family that's what you should do
that is 100 what you should do and if
the whole
culture is telling you that you're wrong
you should be much more confident that
you're right because the culture has
gone completely crazy
uh best of luck in all of your endeavors
i hope you have a very
very good and fulfilling life even if
all the lunatics are screaming at you
from matt mr knowles resident papist and
lord of kuffe
my question relates to the bedrock of
christianity namely the resurrection
disregarding the highly debated shroud
of turin
is it reasonable to believe that the
story of the resurrection in the story
of the resurrection without any physical
evidence if so does that mean christians
believe a man rose from the dead solely
based on testimony
your thoughts would be much appreciated
and i'd be grateful to hear any reading
recommendations you have on the subject
love the show and keep up the great work
well i wouldn't dismiss the shroud of
turin first of all i mean this is a
little bit of a side note but the shroud
of turin
is i believe worthy of belief
it is for those of you who don't don't
know what the shroud of turin is it is
this object that look is a death shroud
that has the image
it's like a three it's a rather it's
like an x-ray image
of uh of a dead man on it that that
looks a lot like what you would imagine
jesus to look like
and there have been attempts to say that
the dating doesn't work to the right
place but those have been debunked
and no one has any idea really what this
could be it
it seems that the image has has been
emitted through some
burst of light like an x-ray it's not
paint
it's not there's nothing like that so
yeah anyway i i just think the shroud of
turin is is
quite good evidence but yes my belief in
the resurrection does not hinge on the
shroud of turin
we have there are 500 eyewitnesses to
the resurrection
they're written about in in accounts
that were compiled
within just decades of the
crucifixion and the resurrection if this
was just completely bogus first of all i
don't think the accounts would would
match up quite in the same way that they
do
but also you would have other accounts
of people saying this is completely
bogus you would have people
disproving it but a lot of people
attested to the resurrection then you
have the lives of the apostles
all of whom i guess they could all be
just totally nuts
but they don't seem like they're totally
nuts and it seems weird to me that all
of them would seem so totally nuts and
it seems weird that they would seem so
persuasive and logical
to all the people at the ends of the
earth that they traveled to to spread
this message of the resurrection the
good news
it seems strange to me if they so if we
say they weren't lunatics
if they were just liars and deceivers i
don't really know what they would get
out of it
most of them all but almost all of them
died because they were preaching that
message
at various places on earth thomas dies
in india paul
and peter are killed in rome
so that that's a little strange to me
and moreover if you're saying
if you're saying that it's a little
strange to believe in this event
the central event in the history of the
world
because uh we're just doing it based on
testimony
how do you believe in anything other
than things that you can see
with your own eyes how do you believe in
anything and by the way
even something you see with your own
eyes can deceive you later on because
memories are
somewhat fickle so how do you believe in
anything why it's
by applying your faculties of reason
to perception and to testimonies that
you have heard how do we know that
aristotle lived how do we know that
napoleon lived
for that matter how do we know that we
went to the moon how do we know
that the sun is going to rise tomorrow
how do we know
that george washington
[Music]
really lived and fought a revolution how
do we know any of this stuff
it's based on testimonies and some are
more credible than others and it seems
to me that the
testimony of the resurrection is
far from being unbelievable or or
incredible or something
you know it's incredible in the sense
that it inspires awe but it seems to me
that
some of the most credible testimony in
the history of the world look
at how people believed how many people
believed at it what what that impelled
them to do
and what that has brought forth as a
matter of our civilization from justin
hey michael
i look forward to your show every
morning while working from home thank
you that's very nice
i recently pre-ordered your book do i
get a ding for that is that a plug
technically if i'm reading his
letter okay the judges have ruled no
dick
oh no okay we got it okay we got a ding
we got a ding that's fine
uh anyway he goes up i ran into a little
conundrum i was hoping you could help
with is it better to order your book
through amazon to boost the amazon
numbers of conservative literature
or is it better to order through your
publisher to avoid giving money to
amazon
while also getting a signed copy i'm
hoping you could advise since i have not
been able to sleep at night because of
this thank you very kind of you to worry
about this
well you can get an autographed first
edition and so a little bit more money
it's not much more money i think it's
like
the book lists for about 29 bucks it's
discounted on some of the websites to
like 22 23 bucks
and you can get a signed first edition
for 30 bucks so
you can do that if you're interested to
your broader question i'll actually
broaden this out even beyond my own book
though i do love to plug it which is
should conservatives
be uh patronizing these these companies
that hate us
in some cases no where it's easy enough
to switch
probably not but in a case like amazon
where amazon just is the store right
they just dominate the marketplace and
they especially dominate the marketplace
for books then i don't think that
we need to hold ourselves to the
standard where we never use those
companies
and we're going to be so ideologically
pure i would go further than that and
say no we should use the companies when
we have to use the companies or when
they dominate the marketplace
and then we should use politics to
punish those companies and
drag those companies back in line into
not
undermining our constitutional republic
i don't this is
this is what the left would do and they
would do it to immoral ends
but they would recognize political
reality and use it to their advantage
and i think the right should do that
as well coincidentally this is uh
alluded to in
in that book that you're very kindly
ordering
from matt dear michael my father is
convinced that lincoln was a bad
president because he used slavery as an
excuse to greatly increase the power of
the federal government
over the state governments my dad says
that this paved the way
for the huge governmental overreach we
are seeing today i tend to disagree
i think governmental overreach largely
began with wilson and the administrative
state and that lincoln keeping the union
together was a good thing what do you
think of lincoln
and do you have any book recommendations
that are fair to both sides of this
argument over lincoln came for knowles
state for news thank you very much
i'm pro lincoln i like lincoln i i'm not
saying that there
are no questions that you can make about
his political career i'm not even saying
that the radical question of whether or
not
you had to fight this bloody bloody
civil war and rip the country apart over
the issue of slavery in order to
get rid of slavery i'm not even saying
that that's out of the question
a lot of other countries got rid of
slavery around the same time we did and
they did it without a bloody civil war
so it would it have been possible maybe
though i sort of doubt it
but this gets to the heart of a question
that i think conservatives are debating
right now which is
states rights very important federalism
very important
local power very important
but rights in the abstract take an
object
the right to do what states rights to do
what
and lincoln had a much clearer moral
vision here
he said yeah we like states rights but
not states rights to just do
profoundly evil things
apply this to abortion do the states
have a right to get an abort you know
to have abortion there are two schools
of thought on this the really mainstream
one on the right
is that yes you know if we got rid of
roe v wade it would go back to the
states and some
states could have in the sub states
couldn't the stronger argument though
actually which is gaining ground on the
right
and is pretty persuasive even to me who
used to think of the other argument
is now the 14th amendment you can't do
it you can't kill people like that no
not even if the states want to
the state's rights to do what when we
think about our freedom of speech speak
free speech to say what freedom of
belief freedom of religion
of freedom to believe what what are we
actually talking about we got to get a
lot more concrete
because politics has not only form but
substance too
and that is really what's going to
separate the good guys from the bad guys
in the country
that we want to be from the country that
we don't want to be and we need to get
much more serious
about figuring out what that substance
is i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
see you on monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin